freunde und fans zusammen mit luca de
ich bin der zweite kommt von graf und
richtig guten start erwischt bekommen
holz wächst ja okay dann auf mein
rückwärts rohstoffe best of das gefühl
rückwärts gelaufen aber ich habe doch
eher lästig fällt erst gar nicht echt
doch hinter mir bist du in der kirche
ich habe so viele leute in die kirche
kommen richtig viele hingucker ein
stockwerk nach oben
da sind des todes viele also wohl schon
in runde für den aufgenommen da bin ich
aber relativ schnell gestorben am
gesamten land gepackt hat ein schocker
nach oben wie kommt man dann nach oben
okay ich bin oben wenn eine hochbahn
boxe ich denn ich bin da recht bei dusty
okay wenn da einer kommt
ich habe es total okay ich hab ein level
rückrunde bei denen aufgenommen star
games könnt euch gerne gucken steht in
dem schreiben
darin schlagen sind der sache was hast
du denn ich habe viel holz axt schwere
rüstung für mich einmal gar nicht auch
hier kann man die glocken läuten
eine glocke läutet eine glocke
schließlich doch ein bewusstes den
handel scanne leitern naja im wasser
du bist du hier
der tag ist das ne kiste der denkt der
denkt dass ein könig komm her denkt der
denkt hinterher ich bin hinter dem gar
nicht wo bist du
lukas bauer lukas nein ich komme mir
nicht hoch
ich bin im wasser von der kirche ins
wasser in den see
okay aber ich habe ein kitzel ja aber
ich habe heute zum baum lukas und baum
lukas muss gleichklang meister-bafög um
lukas lukas dlouhy ich bin halbwegs
hinter dieser mal wohin gelaufen sind
dann nach rechts und dann nach links
nach links beim ersten wir beieinander
am see wo er selber war nicht mein gott
ich weggeboxt
lukas mein gott alte jetzt einfach mal
direkt hinter mir ich hab doch als
zweieinhalb herzen den abo bist du musst
mich retten alters bin in meinem anderen
sehe ich in die map pilot zum
allerersten mal ich will dort auch zum
aller ersten mal ja junge ich muss
irgendwie mein leben aufbauen
aber ich habe keinen plan b dieser typ
ist auch noch haben kann
ich denke die beiden ineinander so dass
die beiden sich eventuell boxen das war
ja auch immer so du musst du denkst
normal denke ich nach la
ich bin eine völlig aus dem kilic schon
diesen komischen baum lukas erst gleich
tot
wenn ich bock drauf habe überlegt hat
mich töten soll oder nicht
er versteckt sich zwischen bäume und ist
einfach mal tot okay okay ich bin drin
das domizil auf mal weg vor dem ist bist
du das nein
denn da wo bist du ich weiß aber eine
kiste jugend aber ich kann jetzt keine
kisten nehmen weil ich bin des todes auf
verfolgungsjagd auf wo bist du ich will
was tut er noch zwei herzen
ich hab hier herzen kommen dass dort
dorf weiß wo das dorf ist wir stehen
aber mal so viele menschen
ich bin bei der kirche aber eine andere
kirche egal bleibt da drin ich komme da
hinein
ich muss wieder laufen wann hinter mir
leute sind okay alter ist es jetzt mein
fleisch wohlleben alter sag mir wo du
bist
dann machen wir ja laut ihm zu zeigen
habe einfach mal der ganze ganzen kuchen
aufgegessen gerade rücken
ich auch nicht
aber ja
japan ist einer war die alle viel besser
sachen man das kann man schwer ich bin
fast tot ich bin tot der einschlag und
ich bin direkt hinter mir mein gott ich
boxe den jetzt geschafft doch niemals
alternate tod getötet du musst einfach
schlagen bis ich bei dir bin oder wie
seht ihr noch bessere sachen von mir
alte hose oder so ich sehe dich bring
ich habe ihn einfach wenn ich war
weggelaufen ich vielleicht kurz zuvor
weg zum norris einfach tot gestorben
zugesetzt meine ausrüstung sehen sollen
stellt die karte auf sub todes kleinen
egal ich ihm noch andere dran
hey leute und dass wir wieder zurück in
der nächsten runde
wenn man noch zusammen mit dem
verrückten jungs vertiefen laufen von
dir aus heute ist holz sagt georg auge
auf die leiter wo ich im laufe und dann
leicht links von der leiter okay finde
ich nicht ich sehe ich nicht wie ich
dich nicht zu roten aus dann auf dem
hügel zu möbel zu mögen zu mögen was den
hügel wusste er da am einem rand der
piste und ich bin schon tot
naja nach kohle auf mit dem schwert
nicht nur standen dann für mich hk für
mich plötzlich auf den rost noch
schlechter steht immer direkt am strand
letztes mal nicht so schlecht ich hätte
gar nichts bei mir lag traten business
bisschen nein egal ich boxe den jetzt
egal was der hatte ich boxe bin jetzt
einfach
es kann wetten abgeschlossen werden die
wette nicht wird nicht was du rettest
weniger gelungen wo ist der überhaupt
weg ich werde in den haag
man kann wie kommt man zum nächsten
spieler ich dachte schlagen aber da
komme ich nicht vorwärts und nur
manchmal
linksklick schlagen ja irgendwohin wo
kein blog ist ok jetzt schicken wir ein
bisschen den szene
ich gehe jetzt mal diese pause ja ich so
heißt jack of the day kraft ok ok dahin
ich sehr rechts nahmen aber ich denke
dass besser ausgerüstet letztlich weil
er hier überall schon war der blöde
besser als andere buzzword man meistens
nicht guckt mich an ja braucht man
rathaus
ich bin oben drauf das geld dem schwert
die mx erfahrung wusste der ist wird er
besser ausgerüstet ich wusste doch nicht
das machen wir nicht so anlauf weiter
gleich blöd gucken
ich verfolge das team nicht auch noch
einer irgendwo ich muss mich erst mal
wach werden an die touristen welcher
schnauze bis direkt am anfang gestorben
war
dafür habe ich eine andere und viel
länger aufgehalten du bist eigentlich
immer sofort gestorben
der zweier ohne und ohne witz ist eine
mal mit der hand das andere mal verfolgt
er mich einfach und sagt dann ich bin
seine route gelaufen
seine ehre ute schreibt route ohne
mensch möchte dass ich mir auch so gute
hat gute er meinte auch nicht die route
mit dem ohr sondern die orphan dem
nikolaus der die schlägt weil du böses
er ich bin seine route gelaufen ist
laufen wird zusammengeklappt 2 verbaut
mich zwei verfolgen mich boxen die sich
da vorne boxen die sich da boxen die
sich die boxen sich die boxen sich oder
wirklich nicht muss der andere hinter
mir ist auch weg kräften alles läuft ich
die gegend und sieht wie sich zwei boxen
doch das war nur zwei achsen beim
geschlechtsakt bisschen jolo hier machen
aber ich würde ja nichts ich gehe erst
mal mein hochhaus vornehmlich abhalten
wollte ist okay
mach das mach ich bin jetzt die seite
was gesehen trotzdem voll staat bekommen
beobachtest du mich ja konkreter so
richtig gegner
doch es ist verflixt findet nichts ja
ich von den vier mal her bin ich gerade
hab ich dich verloren
du kannst es auf jeden fall gut
mitfliegen
ja ich bin herr gateway kraft hier ist
auch ärger dann müsste ich komme nicht
aus dann müsst ihr hier noch eine kiste
sein eigentlich nie das keine kiste cool
aber ich glaube nach wird das amt von
roger kreft er ist echt gefragt habt ich
dachte vielleicht fällt mir spontan was
ein aber nicht spontan was ein aber nein
der vierte ein bein deswegen war seine
gedanken leistung zu klein
darauf will jetzt einen fetten rhein der
rhein und der geht richtig rein in den
wein
wir wissen einfach die komplette szene
ja ja richtig seyfried
sap ist es die zudem die kiste sache
aber genau die schuhe die ich schon habe
nur ein bisschen besser aber ich mag
meine mx lieber ich habe eine menge ich
haben einfach eine uhr
was bringt mir eine grube ich selber
nacht wird überhaupt fragt sich was
bringt dem seine uhr
die ist auch voll schwul nein absolut
nicht
ackermann ich verliere die jetzt wird
meine aussprache lange an
denkst du die bedenken seien beständig
zuschauer wieder sein ich verstehe nicht
was die rede was das für ein mensch kann
man die antworten
wir wollten die hälfte der hacker dena
ist ein hacker da kann man jetzt in den
bildern hier ein beispiel auch aus
gründen nein da warst du des todes
gewalt
der rasierer alte ich hab immer ich habe
in meiner freude hier alle rasiert alter
bekannter hersteller also darf nicht
spoilern mein laptop in solcher bist
mein schwert auf level 1 ist nix schärfe
doch wie komme ich wieder raus alte er
verzaubert sein schwert doch trotzdem
wird davon niemanden geehrt
und er mit seinem pferd wird auf einem
pferd das edle ross nicht erst nur ein
kleiner pieks da wird nicht du liebst an
einer kläranlage mit deinen zwecken
haaren und möchte über krasse doppel
räume oder gar keine und du bist ein bär
anfrage
während frage kläranlage zwergen haare
die wird dann zu einer kleinen sind auch
die heimrechner mein gott das ein typ
manche können einfach gar nichts und
deswegen schneiden die fei compilations
aneinander finde ich eine sehr werke in
zwei sorten
getötet ja hab ich hab mich auf einen
gegner fokussierten mit einer von hinten
und dockt einfach von hinten an
stell dir vor du konzentrierst dich auf
etwas und auf einmal doch jemand von
hinten an
was kennen das gefühl kennt man eher der
bumsti putz beirut leute das war als
printserver games mit lukas duffner von
lukas den kanal von lukas dorf dem wird
noch ein rennen aufgenommen
dem zur gleichen zeit online kam aber
fast zu gleichen zu gleichen fast
zugleich ich weiß nicht ich liebe
ungefähr ab viele ich liebe euch alle
außerdem xbox live servern die sind aber
nur weil sie nicht das sind so die die
sind so sowie die pommes bei mcdonald
sie sind irgendwie dabei aber man man
ist sie trotzdem nicht einfach da wie
sie mag sie ja also nicht gekommen ist
aber die menschen
nein wir sehen und dann eventuell mal
irgendwann wieder wenn ich noch
irgendwann mal ein video aufnehmen kann
und dann für dich sein gefahren da
dürfte das video gerne informieren und
euren daumen abreißen und auf das video
drauf bin
und ja geht alle zu denen
augenscheinlich die runde an und ich
quatsche schon wieder des todes lang und
denen ich geb dir den letzten satz